herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ welten
wir übernehmen heute den kanal und wir
versuchen gut zu zocken
ich muss irgendwie gewinnen morath ich
habe respekt vor älteren personen auf
ein zocken wirte spaß auf mal sehen und
wir werden viel spaß haben
ja ich sags ja schliesslich bloss nicht
ab ich schieße ja egal
du wirst das militär weil ich keine
angst versetzt 4 3 gegen murat sein
ja ja das war schon immer so jetzt immer
so wir drei gegen murat haben keine
angst vor mir selber ja dass ich noch
gespielt als ich hab jetzt mag ich mich
als ich klein war das nicht viel älter
geworden ist die kamera sagen was ich
will es auch um spaß kein respekt vorm
alter jetzt reicht's ergeben und dieses
ding hin
du hast dann den standard 2 oder wie
sagte schon schwarzen lässt doch wieder
bewegung
ihr dürft auch wenn ihr möchtet
es gibt vielleicht die möglichkeit
dauergast ein erstellen das ist
eigentlich als ob du den stein auf das
gaspedal drückt aber gegen gewarnt dazu
gibt es noch die schlosserei die hilft
auch noch mal und nur du braucht die
steuerung nicht weil ich bin schlau
genug
[Gelächter]
und wo kann ich ihnen abschießen
genau hier bekommst dann gleich es gibt
diese großen schönen fragezeichen der
vater einfach geben dann ist oben
ist so ein drehrad der messung lotterie
habe sonst anlockte was eines gibt kann
es da es gibt pilzes stern ich verrate
es nicht weiß was ist es raus hin und
benutzten tut ihr das dann hier da ist
so ein träger wie wir sie ja genau der
unterricht wird stoppt ihr die diesen
diesem casino mäßigen so und dann habt
ihr was
wenn ihr dann noch mal da draufdrücken
schießen schießen das ding weg und
wirklich hamann und murat für die profis
wenn du den knopf gedrückt hält und dann
auch diesen kleinen kreuzer nach hinten
drückt dabei nimmt dann liegt alles für
die frau muss man nicht einfach nur
müssen was gelegenheit spaß nicht immer
nur gewinnt wer spaß und machen weiter
aufgeklärt hätte es damals acht und
graphen ist bewiesen aussteuerung ein
bisschen älter menschen abzuzocken
alba spielt aber nur ein spiel auch nur
beim stehen jetzt müssen wir erstmal
richtig schön abgerissen schlacht ganz
schnell oder 150 e klasse machen
er gibt es eigentlich figuren die
schneller sind als andere eigentlich ist
es egal weil du wirst so oder so mit
jeder figur verlieren du kannst auch
zwei figuren nehmen das machen es macht
mir da sehe ich wenigstens schon nämlich
nicht einfach donkey kong tun was am
besten zu mir als mensch verliert am
schönsten ist es wenn peter vor mir ist
durch peter durchaus auch mal wie es in
gratis schönen auto die langsamsten gar
nicht vermisst wenn wir was mit
bestätigen
ich habe angst beim beschleunigen da ist
bei mir auch so mit wegen richtig
rasieren und rasiere ich so richtig im
turnschuh ich habe schon geholt
das sieht man doch und zwar ich würde
vorschlagen ist spielt den panzer kann
die kuhweide
der bassist fahren wird und es geht
[Musik]
ja ich wünsche euch ein fernsehgerät
oder mit der auswahl hatte
[Musik]
warum bin ich jetzt peter terting das
gesehen bin ich fertig ich habe euch
alle abgezogen so ganz kurzes resümee
der ersten runde vorbei
murat wir selbst schon gut erkannt hat
ist ja etwas geworden ja ich glaube die
altbesitzer melitta weihnachtsmenü
länger gefahren ist mit 83 72
jetzt ist es folgendermaßen es gibt aber
wir spielen einen cup der cupsieger darf
am ende hier triumphieren das ist noch
lange nicht vorbei es geht jetzt noch
drei weitere kennen ja also wir haben
mal was vor uns so und jetzt kommt's
runde zwei
[Musik]
ich glaube kinder nicht gewinnen lassen
das ist voll der folge höher anspielen
naja man muss auch mit dem mac mit
negativen erfahrungen klar kommen ein
helikopter eltern beim britischen labour
wählerin ein thema sein
ich wollte ich nicht ab
[Musik]
du bist du ich bin rechts mit links
einmal und hat die steuerung faltigen
achter hat einen lehrer sogar ich dachte
das wäre im leben
[Musik]
ich will nicht in falsche richtung
du hast wieder ein jahr verloren ich
appelliere die danke wer murat abgehängt
der wettbewerb gegeneinander seine
abdeckung
peter fährst du ein auto hat mich nicht
gewundert
ich hab ihn sicher scheint ich wirklich
nicht mehr fahren ehrlich nicht mehr wie
ich sein möchte
eine lange strecke sogar du bist am ziel
vorbei gefahren dreht es durch wand
natürlich die ich gesehen habe wie die
gefahren bis für diese ganz tolle siege
haben
ich habe mich gerade übergeben
das gibt's doch nicht so wie
freundschaft ich will ja wir können
spielen und spaß haben
ihr beide seid seid gut ich hätte jetzt
das zugleich eröffnung geht du kannst
mit blumen werfen wie du willst ich
werde dich trotzdem abschnitt ich habe
jetzt nicht doch du bist doch auch
mussten geheißen doch alle mandy wenn
die jetzt weiß ich warum die welt
gewählt
[Musik]
die sind mir die wende genommen als sie
an mandy erinnert hat deswegen
hundertprozentiger zenon wegen der
senioren damit sie sehr wohl gibt ihr
mit mir vor 15 jahren war immer in der
schule erklärt dass man mit zwei retten
und einer grundschullehrerin daher gut
und mache gott und ich gingen also schon
lehrerin die ich noch fertig machen
würde es die grundschullehrer wurde die
zwei kinder verlieren das gibt's doch
gar nicht und der vorschlag gemacht
stattdessen brachten aber
also noch nicht schön die banane fahren
dieser war am strand erwischt wieder auf
die straße richtung abgeschossen wir
sind auf der insel nur wer hat schon
wieder diesen geist werden das ist gut
das ist taipeh die denkmalschutz mit
älterer mann hat man sonst einen schönen
konter den rücken
er steht jetzt nicht mehr
ich bin dass wir auch im doppel eine
eigene seite müssen wir lehren
abgeschossen vor anderen seite vom
rentner weil jetzt auch nicht was los
ist eine scheibe
mir leid ich musste sich abschließen
das war immer wieder durch sein ehrgeiz
angekratzt ist ja schon wieder aus ja
trainiert kann man das tragen habe ja
das kann man es auch schneiden werden
ich habe gerne grundschullehrerin an
meinem ganzen leben lang verträgt das
ist nur ihr eure positive aura
da habe ich mich weil ich da wieder raus
reden sie hat zu lange gedauert da wir
schon mal den namen katzen pietsch kurz
übergeben vielleicht danke kommt ist
nummer drei das besteigen um 62 auf
platz zwölf wer bis jetzt wieder von uns
wäre ich glaube ich glaube die zwei
haben vergessen wer sie sind glaube ich
gerne sein kann es sein gemeint ich bin
so okay jetzt kommt die letzte runde
jetzt geht es um alles
seine sieben punkte in der gesamtwertung
voraus man muss schon mal passieren wenn
wir das erleben möchte könnte wenn du
jetzt richtig schlechte auf die mütze
kriegt und ganz weit hinten bist und
erst mal ganz vorne dann ist einiges
möglich im parador hast schon super
das ist doch toll das heißt meine taktik
ganz ganz einfach
sally einfach abschießen wo es nur geht
das in mindestens 17 richtig nein am
ende und melitta und deine punkte
zusammen zählen kriegst du mich fertig
das stimmt alles
gemeint sind gewinner was ich mir
karussell
ja
der ausbau ist die ganzen auto macht das
super so besonders
derweil läuft da was zwischen euch was
ich nicht wir sind partner
hier sind passspiel party 82
gleichgemacht
morath natürlich nicht in ruhe lassen
ich glaube ich bin einfach entweder
einfach schuldig bin nicht leicht ist es
ist alles gut
klassische entschuldigung sieht wenn
sich gegenseitig abschnitt ja es ist
nicht so wie in einer fahren lassen
keiner sagt ich weiß nicht ich bin da
ganz kalt und ich war es so schön
abgeschossen die partie fährt er wieder
in solche klappte hat irgendwann einmal
die personalien hatte ganz ehrlich
inzwischen hier stimmt was ich keine
chance mal was kaputt gemacht habt
linken die sich ungefähr die fans den
spruch traue keinem über 80 warst du
etwas gedreht hier liegt die mitte
spielt einfach
ich weiß aber die
ich finde es gut wäre sogar ein lied vor
mir so groß ist überholt 53 hektar den
menschen vor ort geschossen aber ich
kann mir nicht geschossen
belangt das ist aber aufrichtig erfreut
das ist ja du kommst hat völlig
identisch ist liegt für euch auch
herzlichen glückwunsch
[Gelächter]
rang fünf jahre später hat wie fühlt es
sich an verlierer zu sein
das hat mich ganz ehrlich meine freunde
mich jetzt gesehen ich habe gegen eine
grundschullehrerin und die netten hat
wir machen das jetzt kommen wir die
kinder machen
das schwarze rad es geht um den spaß
sagen nein hat keinen spaß dann hat mich
gewonnen
seit ich drei bis acht andere stellen ja
also es ist was anderes
kannst ja mal ein kuchen backen du hast
nicht nur die tolle kochsendung du hast
auch du bist auto davon das ist für mich
heute
da wenig dies so ist es ja so tollen
harmonisch zwischen euch natürlich ganz
kurz auf diesen teppich übergeben
nein meint ich würde mich tatsächlich
oft gewonnen hast du sehr cool weil die
gewonnen
[Musik]
für die frau die den dreck wird ja wohl
schon hier dass man sich das was du mir
wird ja das war es also selber erzählt
von sport1 danke sagen trotzdem du
kannst ja noch üben dritter ist zweiter
verlierer
ich war trotzdem werden wir zu viert
außerdem da spielt bist du der zweite
ist der erste verlierer zeigt ist erster
verlierer
ja die beste bin ich ja längst gemacht
stimmen ja hass weg minister und drehst
bist du erst aufgefallen hat ja alle gut
entziehen
weißt du wer du bist du bist es du bist
paderborn des maricas ich finanzminister
hat den pokal verdient ja als
aufpasserin ich würde sowieso die ganzen
dinge umdrehen ja ist milliliter die
erste kenner und dann ist alles wieder
in ordnung
das steht eigentlich so lieb und so
weiter als ich hätte es nicht für
möglich gehalten aber tatsache ich habe
in mario kart gewonnen
ich glaube dass die zwei redner und die
grundschullehrer nicht beschissen haben
so dass man nie kaputt ist ja das sind
doch so was gemacht wird sein pro player
was du hast gmbh wenn ihr noch mehr
zocker wie das sehen wir dann geht
wirklich auf den kanal von senioren
zocken das ist so witzig und
unterhaltsam vor sympathisch da können
euch die ganzen zocker videos anschauen
bis zum nächsten mal es ist immer lustig
ja immer und uns hat einen riesenspaß
gemacht bzw und mit ihrem mann zu
spielen und zu packen und super team ist
einerseits gut gehen kannst du
eigentlich den spielen so wie so eine
band spielen also kein gras spielen ist
okay wir sind pädagogisch dann kann man
mit hunden spielen und kratzen wo ich
geh kaputt machen könnte
jetzt kochen wir kochen und gemalt
das spielt ja auch erstmal heute ich bin
also das wird schwierig glaube ich ich
trau keinem an über 70 nein
ja ich glaube spielt das erste mal und
mal sehen das ist eine
riesenherausforderung wenn wir jetzt
kommen
[Musik]
weiter mich ganz besondere gäste zehn
jahren zeugnis bei mir peter und militär
und wir werden jetzt gemeinsam mit
samira und ella unserem 2
weihnachtsessen weihnachtskekse backen
[Musik]
ich hätte lieber so klassisch zu
das ist was wir jetzt überhaupt noch
[Musik]
ich glaube dieses video wird alles
andere als normal aussieht gut
[Musik]